well when several hundred mostly senior
citizens got really frustrated with the
election results in january and broke
the law
and walked through the u.s capitol
building members of congress were so
afraid cindy cortez is still in therapy
she says
that they built a wall immediately
around their workplace around the
capitol then they brought in the
army to protect them meanwhile our
country
has no southern border effectively you
just saw that and no one's doing
anything that's totally fine
too bad the congress is in mcallen the
question tonight though is why isn't the
state of texas
stopping this it's their border too they
have a national guard
they could shut this down why aren't
they doing that sid miller is the
agricultural commissioner
of the state of texas and we're happy to
have him on tonight mr miller thanks so
much
for coming on now i know you know these
problems are famously complicated but
this one's maybe not that complicated
how about shut down the border why
doesn't texas do that
well we should you know our governor's
i'm glad he's doing something we're
finally you know
responding uh we've he's been in office
seven years i'm
i'm hoping it's not political theater
because we've got the basic questions
aren't even
we he has you know he hasn't gave us his
plan
we need to know where does the wall need
to be built how much of it needs to be
built
what's it going to cost and how do we
pay for it you know those are four basic
questions that
that haven't been answered i'm glad he's
doing something
but we're not we're not doing near
enough the problem i have tucker
is is that is the timeline when we knew
on
november 4th or 5th you know pick a day
or january the 6th when the legal
uh avenues were closed or even on you
know january 20th when biden was sworn
in
we knew that there was going to be open
borders and welcome out was going to be
out
exactly six months ago that's that's
when we should have been doing something
down on the border we should have rolled
out the razor wire where the
where the wall hadn't been built we
should have we should have contracted
our high surveillance
uh aircraft we should have got our own
drones up in the air so we could see
where
the surge is coming for once the surge
is here it's too late
you know but we could have been down
there on the border and when that surge
got here and said
look we don't care what the biden
administration says you're not coming
into texas
well that's exactly right and and i
think most people in texas regardless of
their political affiliation or their
ethnicity
appreciate that you can't have a country
without borders and
we don't have the national guard to
fight in syria actually protecting our
own borders seems like a more pressing
concern
what is preventing governor abbott who i
think wants to be re-elected hard to
imagine but i think he does
why isn't he sending them tonight like
what is that honestly what's the answer
i think he's the only one that can uh
answer that question honestly
uh i don't know why he doesn't i don't i
don't have that so i am glad to see
president trump coming back to texas uh
he's welcome here
he'll be well received in those border
communities down there they love him
down there
uh you know he he won a lot of those
counties and those cities
in the last election have never been
carried by a republican before so that's
right
welcome back mr president we're glad to
have you back
yeah 90 hispanic counties voting for
trump because of the border
commissioner sid miller we appreciate
coming on tonight thank you so much
anytime tucker god bless thank you god
bless hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else